all right let's move on to msnbc i know
it's a completely bananas network and i
know you guys don't watch it and you
shouldn't watch it and i know that most
of the hosts there
are mentally ill crazy people uh but
this joy read really takes the cake
on this stuff she just brings on
conspiracy theorists all the time
she makes up nonsense related to
critical race theory she calls everyone
that doesn't agree with her
a white supremacist and the rest of it
well yesterday
she had texas state house democrat dean
sanfronia thompson on to discuss
what's going on in texas now you may
know that a bunch of the texas state
democrats
have fled they've literally fled texas
and they've gone to d.c because they
don't want to have to vote on this bill
and now it's getting messy in texas
because abbott is saying that they could
they could be arrested on return like
it's a whole crazy situation over there
but notice of course that they don't
tell you what's in the bill they just
tell you it's evil and racist and scary
and now
there's going to be scary people with
guns stopping people from voting
take a look now they put co-watchers
in um minority areas and they are normal
people of different nationalities in the
areas that they place them
and they are there to intimidate the
workers
not the workers but they can intimidate
the voters and when persons
uh people walk into a poll and they see
these strange persons in their polling
place
looking at them mean spirited
uh is frightening and sometimes they may
just get up and walk out
are they allowed to be armed can they
can those poll watchers be armed
well uh that's a good question
uh particularly since we have just
passed the
permit-less gun bill we know that the
the the the person themselves who uh
presides over the poll can in fact have
a gun but whether the poll walkers would
be permitted to have one
is another question i would predict that
they probably
they probably could i'm sorry these are
crazy people that live in a fictitious
world
okay there are strange people looking
mean and they might have guns
now putting aside just the general
insanity of that like i know that i
guess if you're watching msnbc that
sounds like something like
oh my god because of these republican
bills the republican bill must have some
sort of provision that says
that strange people with mean looks
that they are going to be standing
outside the polls well let's even
pretend that that was true that there
was something in the bill
that encouraged strange people with mean
looks to stand outside the polling place
and let's
even say that those people had guns
you're not going to believe this but
those people wouldn't know i mean first
off it's just not true
but those people would not know which
way you're going to vote so you'd still
be allowed to vote
what they are doing is the worst sort of
fear-mongering
craziness possible they don't mention
anything
that's in the bill they mention things
that they purport to be in the bill that
involve
strange people and the way they might
look at you
and then oh people have guns in texas
and then we're going to allow for guns
there
and then i guess they'll just be
shooting democrats right like we're just
going to people outside who'd you vote
for
democrat like come on they just
they're just don't watch msnbc i know
you don't
i know you don't but if you have a
friend that watches msnbc
you know what if you have a friend that
watches msnbc
and you send them an email and you say
to them
dear so-and-so i don't want you want you
to watch msnbc anymore it's not good for
you
okay and then they write back to you and
then they say
okay i won't watch it anymore because
you've given them a couple reasons give
them some bullet points maybe link them
to one of my videos
for the first 50 people that do that
and we get responses where you actually
they say to you okay
i've decided i'm not going to watch
msnbc anymore we'll give you
i don't know we'll give you a couple
months free at rubinreport.locals.com
because we must
bring sanity back to america and what
you just saw there is a completely
fictitious made-up story being delivered
by joy reid talking to this democrat who
fled the state
fled the state shirked her
responsibilities as
a democratic congresswoman from texas
just like a whole bunch of the other
ones did
so that she can go on these tv shows and
pretend that strange people with evil
they're gonna give them the evil eye
lordy lordy